well since the arrest of longtime donald
trump advisor Roger stone the press has
rallied around people who arrested him
and around a very specific
interpretation of events it was
completely justified they say for the
FBI to show up with enough armed agents
to overthrow a Central American country
and if stone says he was upset by all
that while he must be lying FBI had
information that he might try to destroy
evidence so they went in I think with an
appropriate level of apprehension they
had every reason to believe he was going
to destroy evidence he had threatened
witnesses or a witness at least and he
was he was playing hardball back how
does this differ from other people
surrounding a house for a raid from the
FBI I don't think it's that different by
the way the guy spent the entire day in
front news cameras clearly he was
traumatized who would put that mud guy
on TV I mean it's really just a disgrace
I would say the former CIA director John
Brennan speaking of disgrace insinuated
that stone was Hannibal Lecter's
long-lost cousin watch this what
happened with Roger stone was in keeping
with the standard operating procedures
of the FBI they were conducting an
arrest and executing a search warrant
and let's not forget Roger stone has a
fair amount of sort of unstable
activities and comments that he had made
stealing someone's dog telling somebody
Randy credit coke prepare to die this is
not somebody you want to trifle with
trifling now Brennan the guy you just
saw talking once lied to the public you
me and the rest of us about killing
civilians with drone bombs but that's
not a big deal really he's still got a
cable contract so what does Rogers don't
have to say but the coverage of his
arrest well we're gonna ask him he is on
the set tonight Roger stone thank you
for joining us aren't you jack order no
actually the judge said today that she's
considering one she asked for the
government and for my attorneys to
submit their thoughts about that I'm
gonna refrain from speaking about the
specifics of the indictment because I
think I have addressed it to the extent
that I'm going to but I'm very
interested in what's happened here
because one of my neighbors has now
signed a sworn affidavit who was out
walking their dog and the CNN crew their
truck showed up roughly a half an hour
thirty five minutes before the FBI
I live on a dead-end street the street
was sealed but they were allowed to stay
in position right in front of my house
now if I was dangerous which is the
premise of this raid
why were they allowed to stay within the
danger zone why would they put in harm's
way the idea that I'm a flight risk is
ridiculous I don't have a valid passport
although I support the Second Amendment
I don't own a gun there were no firearms
in the house and I've been under
investigation for two years so what
information did the FBI have that I
would destroy evidence why would I wait
till I don't know John Brennan who is a
liar John Brennan who brought such a dog
kitten
look again that's in the indictment and
I will address it at an appropriate time
because it's not true but first of all
I've written extensively on animal
welfare rights for the Daily Caller and
have worked very hard to stop the
government from conducting inhumane
scientific experiments on dogs and cats
but I mean you're a dog lover of the
first water loss but more importantly
John Brennan perjured himself twice
before the Congress once regarding the
role of the Steele dossier and the FISA
warrants and secondarily regarding his
breaking into the computers of a Senate
committee looking into illegal torture
by the CIA just like people with drones
not but not a big deal but he happy but
he's not being prosecuted like mr. Comey
mr. mchabe rod Rosenstein mr. ray
general clapper of course who said that
well know there's no better data
collection process and then of course
Hillary Clinton the person I guess all
those people have perjured themselves
but I'm being prosecuted for perjury
well they never gave the finger to the
man though and that may be your main
crime in my view they but let me ask you
about the day of the arrest yes so that
was I guess oh we could go today you
said that CNN remained within the
security perimeter yes during a raid
that clearly they must have considered
dangerous because they had automatic
weapons at least one arresting officer
had two rifles with him and a sidearm
that's a lot of guns how do you think
CNN was allowed to stay there how does
that make sense I don't know and I hope
Senator Lindsey Graham in the house
looking's we'll get to the bottom of
that because I'd like to know who signed
off on this raid I mean the the main
reason that the gag order concerns me is
because I need to be able to raise the
money to mount a defense right they have
unlimited taxpayer dollars three
platoons of Ivy League left-wing lawyers
to prosecute me they have just given us
an enormous amount of material in
discovery that we have to go through
three terabytes according to their press
release unless people can go to stone
Defense Fund comm and unless I have a
forum to promote it I can't possibly
register what grounds could they could
they just end your First Amendment
rights well the day as you know that
gagged Paul Manafort in his trial
because I would be prejudicing witnesses
partly I'll be producing a jury well
that was the whole purpose of this raid
was to poison a journey to hold me up as
public enemy number we use a cable news
channel as a PR operation to get their
message out so if they gag you and take
your First Amendment rights away does
that mean that they're no longer allowed
to leak to see none against you well
it's an interesting question but the
whole purpose of the gag would be so I
don't poison a potential jury pool but
they've just poisoned a potential jury
pool by making me look like El Chapo or
Pablo Escobar so it just seems a little
bit one-sided so they can arrest you
with overwhelming force and automatic
weapons and armored vehicles and stun
grenades and then they can force you not
to speak in public but they can still
say whatever they want about you to news
organizations and Lee and leek I mean
two years of leaks as you know that I
was going to be arrested every other
Tuesday has destroyed my business the
censorship of my show on info wars and
the censorship of my Facebook page has
hurt my book sales dramatically I'm a
New York Times bestselling author so
this is this is part of the plan destroy
you financially so like general Flynn
you have to plead guilty to something
you didn't do unbelievable we are always
welcome on this show gag order or not
Roger stone thank you thank you